la parole autochtone si c'est melissa
maulin depuis cette semaine je me suis
permis de sortir nature bien sûr à
distance sociale respectable et un des
sujets justement qui m'ont inspiré
beaucoup c'est la nature glycines que la
nature nous donne les messages qui ne
sont envoyés par la nature pourquoi j'ai
eu ce sujet là encore c'est que j'ai
écouté le nouveau film de jeff barnaby
c'est-à-dire blood quannum pour ceux qui
savent pas blog.com
et bien c'est le quota sanguin c'est ce
quota qui décide si tu autochtones ou
non selon la loi sur les indiens et bien
dans le film le côté sanguin sauvent des
vies puisque si tu as du gotha sargue un
autochtone une pompe à la maladie de la
pandémie qui se passe dans le film est
situé bain malheureusement pas
autochtone dans le quota sanguin tu
deviens un zombie pourquoi est-ce que je
veux parler de nature et de films de
zombies c'est que beaucoup de gens au vu
des listings à travers la publication
tout le retard de publication du film la
sortie du sommet était prévu au mois de
mars
et c'était en plein début de la pandémie
sadio cornes commençait à être obligé de
rester dans nos maisons est un film sur
la pandémie qui se passe en temps de
pandémie
c'était quand même un grand hasard il
est sorti un mois plus tard et on voit à
travers le message qui se passe dans le
film le fait que en écoutant pas la
nature eh bien c'est ce qui est arrivé
la pandémie de son be est arrivé c'est
signe de la nature on en entend parler
beaucoup surtout dans les communautés
autochtones que ce soit de nord au sud
on a beaucoup de professeurs d'histoire
de storytelling qui transmettra de
génération en génération on a des
preuves des prophéties historique dont
on a des prophéties moderne donc cette
transmission d'histoire et de voir des
signes dans la nature est quand même
très forte dans la culture des premières
nations
là je pense à certaines des prophéties
qui sont les plus connus la prophétie
des sept feux ou le boeuf au groupe
carrefour men c'est à dire la femme du
bison blanc qui est venu donner des
médecines et a dit je vais revenir un
jour
quand vous en aurez le plus besoin et là
on voit sur le territoire en soi même
la naissance d'un bison pour la première
fois depuis des décennies donc des
signes s'accumulent on va parler de
beaucoup de sorte de prophétie je pense
le ghost dance qui était une prophétie
qui a été de vous danserez du territoire
et les hommes blancs disparaître en soit
c'était quand même à une époque aux
états unis où justement les gens qui
faisaient le gros stand mais ont été
massacrés par les soldats américains et
certaines personnes au diable cette
prophétie se réalise et plus qui sont
allés dans un meilleur monde vous voyez
on peut interpréter les prophéties de
plusieurs manières les historiques comme
les modernes
je pense à une prophétie moderne qui est
beaucoup utilisé de ces temps ci et
c'est la prophétie du serpent alors on
dit que un jour des grand serpent noir
allaient traverser le territoire manger
les territoires et manger les enfants
essaient souvent associée aux plans et
aux sables bitumineux dont on utilise
encore beaucoup les prophéties comme
étant des outils pour diriger notre
manière d'action de fer où notre pensée
et je me suis dit mais est ce qui est
quelque chose dans les prophéties
autochtone qui est meilleur que dans les
prophéties non autochtone et qu'est ce
qui fait la différence et bien en se
rendant compte
historiquement les prophéties des
programmations n'était pas directive
elle était là pour avertir elle était
libre d'interprétation
et elle pouvait aussi guidé les pas
alors que beaucoup des prophéties plutôt
comme la fin du monde la bible était
vraiment très directive
il faut que tu fasses assas à la fin du
monde arrive et l affaire si c'était
beaucoup plus dans une direction très
précise
on a vu que certaines personnes ont pris
ces prophéties l'homme est entré comme
l'argent comptant et ça leur fait
historiquement certains c'était certains
débordements qui ont causé la mort de
beaucoup de gens alors que les
prophéties des premières nations sont
vraiment d'en regarder les saigne
regardez autour de vous c'est pas dur en
ces temps ci de changement climatique de
pandémie de voir des signes la nature un
peu partout de voir le retour des
animaux parce que l'absence de l'humain
permet cet espace le devoir que
nos animaux ne revienne plus haut même
saison ou qu'on ne trouve plus la
nourriture qu'on peut trouver autrefois
donc ce bois ses singles c'est quand
même pas magique c'est juste une
observation logique mais pour un peuple
qui est dans la tradition orale et qui
fait transmettre des histoires et peut
pas écrire des livres
c'était une manière de pouvoir faire
vivre ses professeurs et ses singles et
cette relation à la nature très très
très serrée qu'elle avait alors vous
comprenez voir des signes c'est pas une
si mauvaise chose si ces signes sont
naturels et sont pour la survie de tous
pour le bien être et je pense qu'ils
nous permettent à nous de nous dire
peut-être qu'on devrait suivre les cinq
parce que ils sont assez claires de 7
ans alors vous comprendrez pourquoi
c'est intéressant
vous allez sûrement entendre beaucoup
parler beaucoup de théories présentement
sur les médias sociaux beaucoup
théoriques sont liées aux prophéties
mais aussi qu'ils sont liés à des
théories alors les discussions sont
quand même assez difficile
je dirais qu'il faut s'en inspirer de
cette cause de ce côté de voir des
signes mais ne pas voir des directions
fixe apprend alors n'hésitez pas si vous
avez des questions n'hésitez pas à
partager ses vidéos et je vous souhaite
une très belle semaine